Speaker 1: The Supreme Court on Friday dealt
another defeat to President Joe Biden blocking
his student loan forgiveness program, CNN
reports.
In a stinging defeat for President Joe Biden,
the Supreme Court blocked the administration
student loan forgiveness plan Friday, rejecting
a program aimed at delivering up to $20,000
of relief to millions of borrowers struggling
with outstanding debt.
The decision was six three.
Chief Justice John Roberts wrote for the Conservative
Supermajority.
This will become an issue in 2024.
Biden can try to galvanize liberals by claiming
the conservative court prevented him from
delivering debt relief to voters.
Republicans are celebrating the ruling as
a defeat for a bailout plan.
Republican led states and conservatives challenging
the program say it's an unlawful attempt to
erase an estimated $430 billion of federal
student loan debt under the guise of the pandemic.
Roberts said the Biden administration and
Secretary of Education rewrote the law that
it cannot fairly be called a waiver.
It not only nullifies existing provisions,
but augments and expands them dramatically.
However broad the meaning of waive or modify
that language cannot authorize the kind of
exhaustive rewriting of the statute that has
taken place here.
I have to tell you, this is not surprising.
Every time we we talked about this, for example,
on the bonus.
Speaker 2: Show, a David Pac-Man membership
because six bucks a month.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Pat and I both said.
This is shaky.
While we agree with the policy, this legal
basis is shaky and people would call in during
live calls and say, David, should I stop paying
my student loans?
I owe nine grand.
Should I stop paying them because it might
all get paid off.
And I said, don't take that advice from me.
It's not obvious to me that this is going
to survive.
And it's not obvious to me that it makes sense
to allow interest to continue accumulating
while you wait for this to work its way through
the courts.
And indeed, this was the decision.
So, listen, the Supreme Court has handed Joe
Biden a number of defeats by now.
The most important the most important takeaway
and realization from all of this is.
None of this would be happening if Hillary
Clinton had defeated Donald Trump in 2016.
And I know that there are people in my audience
who don't want to hear this.
There are people who stayed home or voted
someone in or whatever in 2016 under the guise
that Hillary is just too conservative for
me.
Yeah, okay.
Trump's a clown, but not that different from
Hillary Clinton.
And there were people like me and others who
were saying, That's really dangerous.
We're not just pretending that the Supreme
Court issue could be a major issue.
It really could.
Look.
Now, Roe v Wade student loans.
I can't even give you the full list.
Most of this stuff doesn't happen if Hillary
Clinton wins in 2016.
With rumors now of potentially multiple retirements
in the Supreme Court upcoming, I am going
to restate again and again that the Supreme
Court could be a major issue in the next presidential
term.
And it is really important that we remember
that.
And we take 2016 as a lesson as far as that
goes.
So this is the Supreme Court's decision.
This is a loss for Joe Biden.
It is not a massive surprise, but it is a
reminder about the importance of the Supreme
Court.
And we've got a horrible Supreme Court right
now.
I mean, it's the reality.
We have a horrible Supreme Court.
We will continue following it.
We will see what other venues there may be,
if any, for Joe Biden to do student loan forgiveness.
There are.
He could have done it with a different legal
justification.
We've talked about it before.
We will talk about it again.
But that is the Supreme Court's decision.